Oi Prof Cadê o chatinho chatinho
desapareceu toma assim que ele não está
no Instagram samba
Oi mozão eu fui pra ver se vocês dois e
procure um jeitinho aí agora sim linda
agora nada
o Elton John
E aí
eu vou aí
e não é
ah ah ah
E aí
o Ero pois o grande cavalo e
e Ele viveu grandes aventuras e
colecionou histórias incríveis para
custa cinco centavos vender vamos vão
Como assim não tem dinheiro eu tô
falando a hora agora que sua vila corre
perigo ele está pronto para entrar em
Ação as garotas que desapareceram foram
aprisionados dentro deste mural e acabar
de vez com as forças do mal
em uma nova aventura com batalhas épicas
está prestes a começar
E aí
[Música]
o Jackie Chan em contos do caçador de
sombras
é bom a dublagem de seu grande fã é o
mesmo Whindersson Nunes